this is a letter from a fan I don't get
many letters from fans mostly they send
me email but this letter as you can see
is really striking he's got a pretty
striking stamp but that presumably is
just from the US Post Office but it has
got a large patch of a silvery metal
here which it claims is palladium and
here it has got what it claims is gold
and if you turn on the back it's got
something that looks really quite
convincingly like copper and it is then
sealed up with sealing wax the material
that was originally used for sealing up
letters and it's pretty heavy
or heavy for a letter and inside is a
letter with quite tiny writing beginning
dear professor and with a lot of text
which I won't read you all of it but it
has one bit that I really like which
says my friend John and I have
affectionately nicknamed you platinum
sponge after noticing your endearing
hair and then thank you and your
colleagues for providing the citizens of
the earth that's you
such wonderful bodywork and working for
the public good so you felt realized I
felt pretty warm and then I turned the
letter over and look what's on the back
on the back are a number of United
States coins and then there is a model
of a tiny floppy disc which says that it
is 92% silver and seven and a half
percent copper and then a piece here
which says it's 99.99% go and something
here which says that it is 96 percent
platinum now these are pretty heavy
so if they're not gold silver and
platinum they are some quite dense metal
and it's extraordinary
we've had all sorts of presents from
people but never such an array of
expensive elements all in one go just
came through the post this came through
the post do you think it's real we
haven't yet tested them but I think
they're real the only way we can test
them is to take them off the letter and
put them in one of our x-ray
photoelectron spectrum eaters which
might slightly spoil the letter rather
like this here are grains of platinum
this is probably the only time in my
life that I will be able to play with
platinum
in such a casual way but the beauty of
gold as a chemical element is that it's
very unreactive